I grew up in a frightened community I
was born on the eve of the Holocaust
1938 my mother when my brother was born
my mother kept saying she didn't know
whether she would have him in some
bunker or in the basement somewhere we
were all terrified of war and we were
all terrified of what was happening to
the Jewish community it was a powerless
community at the time hard to imagine
today but no influence in Congress no
influence really in any aspect of
politics it was a community that really
felt that they were the guests in
somebody else's country there were
second-class citizens they were
tolerated at best and they had better
behave and it was a community of people
who were very patriotic quite
conservative in their outlook toward
many things people sometimes stereotyped
the Jewish communities being very
radical a community and there are many
secular Jews who were radical during
that period of time some communists and
socialists but in the Orthodox community
I grew up and quite conservative quite
patriotic and frightened is the word I
think I would use more than any other
the message I constantly got from my
parents and grandparents was shush still
be quiet be quiet don't rock the boat
don't do anything don't make your hosts
the real Americans mad at you
whatever you do do quietly obviously it
didn't take with me and I reacted I
think